la décision est extrêmement rare en
milieu hospitalier la suspension d'un
chef de service il s'agit du docteur
pierre michel roux qui dirige le service
de chirurgie cardiaque au centre
hospitalier régional bon secours à metz
il répond aujourd'hui aux accusations
camille ponthieu il pourrait ne plus
jamais exercer la médecine
la décision est tombée ce matin pierre
michel roux chef du service de chirurgie
cardiaque de l'hôpital bon secours de
metz est suspendu de ses fonctions c'est
un comité d'experts de l'agencé
régionale de santé qui a tranché en
cause une surmortalité deux fois plus
élevé que la moyenne nationale
une des explications de ces mortalités
de cette surmortalité tient peut-être
selon le rapport des experts à des
pratiques médicales qui peuvent donner
lieu à perfection en clair pour la rs
des interventions chirurgicales
injustifiée longues et répétées ou
encore une valse des médecins
anormalement élevé aujourd'hui les
experts pointent des dysfonctionnements
graves au sein de ce service de
chirurgie cardiaque
le 11 octobre dernier déjà la direction
avait fermé en urgence le service du dr
roux aujourd'hui se défend dans la cave
de l'inspection qui a succédé à ce
premier rapport je n'ai entendu qu'une
demi-heure par la mission d'inspection
pendant laquelle je n'ai pas été en
mesure d'aborder de précision des faits
qui me seraient reprochés
je demande donc à disposer d'une
information loyale sont ceux qui me
reprochaient à moi même et à mon service
d'un débat contradictoire dossiers de
patients l'appui afin que mes arguments
soient entendus l'ordre des médecins a
également lancé une procédure
disciplinaire à l'encontre du docteur
roux les experts ont deux mois pour
rendre leurs conclusions définitives et
sceller le sort de ce médecin